we're standing on level five
of park royal collection hickory but you
could also consider this a new ground
level
as you can see this level 5 accommodates
the pool deck
the spa the gym and a lot of communal
facilities for the hotel
the building actually incorporates more
greenery more than twice the amount of
greenery
than if you had left the site
undeveloped it's approximately fifteen
thousand square meters of green
surfaces which is roughly the equivalent
of
hong kong park right next to us so what
we wanted to investigate
is how a development in the city
can not only replace the greenery of the
city
but also intensify it by integrating the
sky gardens on every fourth floor we
break down the overall scale of the
building the greenery also helps to
frame the views for
the hotel room so the guests in their
hotel rooms enjoy kind of a
framed view and a lush green environment
almost like a resort feeling
even though we're smacking the city
center in a very dense urban environment
with a project we also aim to give back
to the city
so the building provides sheltered
walkways and cut-throughs
through the site for people to walk past
it also provides a beautiful backdrop
and a beautiful view for the housing
developments behind us
what's driving us in this integration of
landscape and architecture to answer
that you really have to look at the much
much bigger context of the
task and the challenges at hand it
really
is the fundamental question of how we
as a civilization want to live with
unsustainable urban development being
the major contributing factor to
co2 emissions and global energy
consumption
we really have a responsibility to
provide better solutions and to come up
with better typologies
how do we want to accommodate these
millions of people in our cities and how
can we reconcile that in our
relationship
with the natural environment and so
there are many many systems that are
affected by this it's
questions of how do we organize our
transport where and how do we harvest
energy and food how do we integrate
public space
we see our projects as prototypes for
the cities of the future
and singapore can play a really
important role
because not only are we forced to be
innovative because of the land scarcity
that we're facing but also because
of our geographic location climatic
condition
being located in the tropic means that
we can develop typologies here
for many of the new mega cities many of
them are located in the tropical belt
around the globe and yet most of the
existing typologies high density
typologies
are not developed for the tropical
climate zone
in this context integrating landscape
and greenery
in our development is absolutely key
[Music]